ces images de deux hommes dans un
restaurant à moscou peuvent sembler
banal en réalité les s'agirait d'une
rencontre secrète autour de la table
james william thomas ce ford ancien
deuxième secrétaire chargé des affaires
politiques de l'ambassade du royaume uni
et vladimir h horcoff opposants russes
et bras droit de l'ex et navales ni
directeur exécutif de la fondation fbk
fondé par l'opposant
si ces images datent de 2012 ce n'est
qu'aujourd'hui qu'elles ont été
dévoilées
si nous avions plus d'argent nous
agrandir y ont bien sûr notre équipe un
peu d'argent si quelqu'un dépensé je ne
sais pas à 10 dans l'union de leurs
parents pour soutenir cela nous verrions
les choses différemment
mais ce n'est pas une grosse somme
d'argent pour des gens qui ont des
miliaires injuste c'est donc le message
que j'essaie de faire face et dans le
cadre de ma campagne de collecte de
fonds notamment parlant aujourd'hui l'un
des affaires etc
à l'origine de ces images les services
russes de contre espionnage qui
surveillait de près james williams
thomass ford
le fsb le soupçonne d'être un agent non
déclarés du mi6 le service de
renseignement extérieur du royaume uni
lors de cette rencontre l'opposant russe
vladimir h surkov semble demander l'aide
des britanniques et notamment des
informations afin de les utiliser contre
moscou
[Applaudissements]
je suis certain que les services secrets
britanniques possèdent des informations
sur abramovitch usmanov sur les
personnes au gouvernement russe
je pense que la grande bretagne est un
pays européens clés qui a un poids à
jouer et qui dure c'est déjà ça posé sur
envers la russe affaire de gros sous et
d'informations compromettantes pour
faire pression sur moscou pour le fsb
ces échanges illustre clairement
l'ampleur de l'ingérence britannique
dans les affaires russe pour le moment
londres n'a pas fait de commentaire sur
cette affaire